can you describe its form no start from
the beginning what do you think I do
when you're away you think I'm out in
the garden pining looking at the sky why
are you here I gotta leave a day early
your husband's here let me see him he's
extremely ill you have to tell me where
it was but he was doing it was his
decision to go in
something they termed the shimmer we've
sent in drones in teams of people but
nothing comes back but something has
you're a biologist who served in the
military if I knew what happened I could
save his life
the boundary is getting bigger it's
expanding we're talking city-states you
need to know what's inside it's
beautiful
check this out like they're stuck in a
continuous mutation are they understand
they're no sharks have teeth like that
it's not possible you can't cross great
different species yes
well soldiers on the last expedition eat
like crazy or something here kill them
something's come to the fence you're the
fence we have to go back I can't go back
we can camp here tonight
it's destroying everything it's not
destroy
it's making something new